empieza revista de prensa por directo
América por ello saludo en el estudio a
mi compañera Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
Buenos días Hola Andrés Buenos días
Marta vamos a abrir revista de prensa
arrojando un poco de luz a las
diferencias entre los procesos de
disolución del Congreso primero en
Ecuador por parte del presidente
Guillermo lasso pero también en Perú por
parte del expresidente Pedro Castillo ha
habido mucha intención de compararlos en
las últimas horas pero las diferencias
son muy significativas Y eso está
recogido por ejemplo el análisis que
hace medios como voice of America o el
colombiano sí Andrés recordemos que ayer
poco más de cinco meses después de que
Pedro Castillo anunciara esa intención
de disolver El Congreso en Perú
Guillermo lasso el presidente de Ecuador
tomó el mismo camino ahora bien el mismo
el mismo Pues no Y esto es lo que
analizan estos dos análisis tanto de
voice of America como del colombiano
dicen que las diferencias son
significativas y se basan en tres
Pilares los primeros son las
constituciones de ambos países citado
por América un analista llamado Luis
Alberto mía Marín dice que hay una
diferencia de forma y método mientras
que en Ecuador el presidente puede
actuar de manera inmediata con el
decreto de muerte Cruzada que disuelve
el legislativo y El Ejecutivo en Perú el
presidente si quiere disolver el
congreso debe pasar por un proceso tanto
administrativo legislativo y legal lasso
tomó esta decisión mientras estaba en
curso el juicio político en su contra y
acudió a una ley amparada por la
Constitución de 2008 sin embargo
Castillo tomó la decisión antes de que
se anunciara el impeachment en su contra
el 7 de diciembre recordemos que es
cuando el presidente disolvió o quiso
disolver el congreso y anunció que
gobernaría por decreto y además nombró a
un gabinete de emergencia pero nunca
hizo un llamado a elecciones que esto es
una diferencia Clara entre ambos
procesos además la Constitución peruana
textualmente el presidente está
facultado para disolver el congreso si
este ha censurado negado su confianza a
dos consejos de ministros el congreso
peruano nunca negó la confianza a dos
consejos de ministros el 11 de noviembre
del año pasado hubo una presentación de
moción de confianza que el congreso se
votó a negar y entonces Castillo dijo
que eso ya había supuesto una negación a
la confianza de su consejo de ministros
Entonces le quedaría otra o sea ni
siquiera Castillo tendría esos dos
mociones de censura en su contra y el
constitucional peruano le dijo que no
podía cerrar el congreso no por tanto
los analistas dicen que en Ecuador este
proceso es legal y en Perú es ilegal Por
otra parte el apoyo de las fuerzas
armadas no cuya función es defender la
constitución en Perú le dieron la
espalda a castillo y además se
posicionaron a favor de dinavoluarte y
en Ecuador aseguraron que la decisión
era totalmente legítima y además Bueno
pues para intentar disuadir cualquier
intento de subversión popular y después
los destinos de ambos Castillo está en
la cárcel y lazo va a seguir como
presidente bien Marta ahora vamos a
cambiar de tema vamos a pasar a Estados
Unidos porque allí el departamento de
defensa publicó un documento en el que
se advierten que Los Superiores de Jack
techeira El joven acusado de haber
filtrado cientos de documentos
clasificados en las redes sociales le
admitieron previamente pero nunca
tomaron una decisión para sacarlo de la
plantilla de las fuerzas aéreas de
Massachusetts esto lo refleja por
ejemplo el New York Times que dice sí
Andrés bueno se espera primero que todo
que Jack de sheira comparezca mañana
viernes ante el juez David Genesis que
tendrá que decidir si este joven de 21
años acusado de filtrar cientos de
documentos clasificados Pues debe o no
permanecer entre rejas ayer Eso sí el
departamento de justicia presentó un
documento que revela que hubo decisiones
controvertidas por parte de sus
superiores no de Los Superiores de la
fuerza aérea de Massachusetts que es
donde Jack de sheira trabajaba por qué
estas decisiones controvertidas Por qué
supuestamente los funcionarios de la
fuerza aérea ya habían advertido a
jacteseira en septiembre y octubre de
2022 de que no podía tomar notas o hacer
búsquedas profundas en documentos
altamente clasificados Solo fue una
advertencia verbal y una sanción por
escrita Pero en ningún momento se
plantearon destituirlo Solo cuando esto
ya se hizo público entre marzo y abril
de este mismo año Incluso un Sargento
mayor de la fuerza aérea de
Massachusetts le pilló accediendo de
manera totalmente inapropiada a informes
clasificados de inteligencia mundial
conjunta los recordemos no documentos
filtrados en discord que revelaron por
ejemplo que Estados espiaba sus socios o
pues cuáles eran los planes de Ucrania
en el terreno o incluso pues que la
inteligencia rusa Estaba totalmente
permeada por los servicios secretos
estadounidenses este artículo del neor
Times dice además que el departamento de
Justicia sostiene que ahora Jack de
sheeran No puede salir de la cárcel por
razones de seguridad nacional bien Esto
reflejaba el New York Times vamos a
hacer un repaso ahora de lo que dice el
Washington post sobre este tema Además
del Washington dice que el Jack de
sheira filtró estos documentos
clasificados en grupos Donde había gente
Donde había Perdón más de 150
participantes e incluso algunos de ellos
extranjeros por tanto el riesgo a la
seguridad nacional es una causa más que
justificable para que se irá no salga de
la cárcel e incluso sea condenado a 25
años de prisión Jack de sheira sostiene
este artículo del Washington post además
era consciente de la gravedad de lo que
estaba haciendo en esta plataforma donde
filtró los documentos y se jactaba de
hacerlo y el Washington recoge parte de
la defensa de teseira que dice que
quiere ponerlo en Libertad bajo una
fianza de 20.000 dólares y que su padre
sea bueno se ha dicho que puede vigilar
a su hijo si está en libertad incluso
instalando cámaras de seguridad para que
su hijo no vuelva a cometer estos
errores Marta vamos a cambiar de tema
pero seguimos ahí en Estados Unidos
concretamente en Los Ángeles porque hay
titulares este jueves sobre el proceso
exitoso de sindicalización de mujeres de
un club de strippers tras una ardua
pelea revisamos lo que dice quarts y Los
Ángeles Times rápidamente por favor sí
Andrés este sería el primer proceso de
sindicalización exitosa de mujeres de
que bailan en clubs de striptease desde
1996 cuando ya se hizo en un club de
striptease en San Francisco las
bailarinas del stargard
han estado luchando 15 meses contra la
gerencia de este Club que
ha impuesto impugnaciones recurrentes al
final ayer la retiró se espera que este
jueves las bailarinas voten
sindicalizarse y de ser así sería
pionero en Estados Unidos dado que el
club de San Francisco cerró en el año
2013 hay 19 bailarinas que son elegibles
para unirse a este sindicato y además
sostienen pues mejores condiciones
laborales y una Bueno una petición que
puede ser muy obvia pero no tanto a
veces en estos sectores que es
literalmente ser tratadas con dignidad y
con los respetos básicos finalmente que
dice Los Ángeles Times pues Andrés Los
Ángeles Times dice que además las
mujeres han estado todos estos meses
estos 15 meses organizando piquetes a la
salida de este club de striptease en Los
Ángeles e incluso disuadiendo a los
clientes de que entraran y diciéndoles
que dentro del establecimiento no se
garantizaban las condiciones de
seguridad Así que si logran
sindicalizarse será un hito y además
entrarán a formar parte de un sindicato
que acoge a más de 50.000 profesionales
en este sector Muchas gracias por este
repaso sobre lo que dicen los medios de
comunicación nos vemos mañana Nuevamente
gracias Andrés